per tutti ragazzi e veneto che sono le
sono falli genio oggi come promesso
abbiamo il vino dove io proverò a fare
il quiz sull'ip antella e vediamo se hai
studiato sono uscito non 60 da superare
perché quando hai costruito tutto e ho
messo malissimo una vita triste però io
ho iniziato a farli perché ovviamente
non sapevo fare quando korando anni
miete al classico dei nostri video
finalmente ci siete voi dovete
correggerli per qualsiasi allora che io
ovviamente non farò perché io mi conosco
io neanche mezzo errore
franky in pubblico a meno maniche di
palle tra stand aspetta aspetta se lo
aspetta i canali sono i nostri
avete fatto un sacco di roba devono
restituire però non sul vostro canale
madonna non lo sapevo la sorgere a
mykonos parato da chiaro sapeva la
gloria di decio bravo la prima sapevo
perché vi seguo sempre ogni cinque
minuti
sì ci chiediamo quanti libri hanno fatto
i rami da grandi scrittori pure normale
1 2 2 1 2
mi chiamo soraga 122 che scrivono i
libri che schifo che medaglia la logica
delle compreso qual è il giorno in cui
mantella scaricano i video nel loro
secondo canale secondo lei è il mio
canale quella e l'anglo arabo e
suggerisce 40 anni quante
visualizzazioni sul canale di pan della
nottata 10 settembre 2016 da dynatem in
aiuto quante ne avete adesso ai contare
su una rosa all'orecchio norcross anno
vederlo su youtube dai continuamente
adesso faccio il veloce però c'è tempo
wi fi facilità perché qui
andiamo a giocare subito la stellina
serratissima questo qui ma non è che chi
è
addio ad essere la santa con che
espressione facciale
usiamo questo momento per alessio ne
seguiranno questo video contato so che è
successo è importante il matrimonio
importante però torna a casa noi ti
aspettiamo ancora certa fascia non si
può essere così triste con chi sarà lo
speciale 2 milioni nicchia si sente già
arrivato è falso si conquista gli ha
scritto una migrazione è finire peggio
fatto questi giorni naturali si tenterà
con me non me lo ricordavo la figura di
merda epocali l'eroe della bellissima
che c'era lorenzo vestito dai smeraldo
la meraviglia sua voce intanto
pubblicità 16 diversi qualche posto
birichina di ieri copertine di padre gli
archi in che giorno della settimana
ipantellas condizione questa che giuro
che non veramente non lo so abbiamo
anche poi a ritagliarsi amico ben detto
loro allora quella di ragazzi meno male
allora cui chiedo per amanti della
playlist c'è legge blog dei fan della su
quanti video ci sono anche che lo regala
io dico 9 prezioso in questo ha detto no
sbagliato di prima perché avrebbe un
canale youtube dove siete youtube
montato pubblicità va bene questa volta
facciamo vedere un'altra foto di donne
donne che durante il suo agio quando
avremo chiaro in oggi non ha pantella se
la nonna di dati che non è che per un
attimo avuto inaugurato l'ombre è perché
di questo primo rapporto d'amicizia ma
se mio fratello va bene salutiamo la
nonna dei bar della gior
non ci sono state molto offesa perché
accogliesse durante
molto molto offesa è quindi il prossimo
video se arriviamo a 160.000 like marini
hashtag limoni up e facciamola reaction
della non al di là di giulia pennella se
riprenderanno la serie mia madre satana
fatica situazione decidendo è una
domanda importante sila finanzieranno
con il loro libro non si sa
boh ma che finanziare anche mika che
c'avete lo yacht veramente volevamo fare
la seconda stagione con le copie vendute
del inglobato riapertura del grande
contratto il libro non regate non è
quella scritto danni e non dovete
perdere il piacere vedersi contratto per
la seconda stagione che era scritto dai
quindi sono tangibili ai ragazzi questa
è bella proprio che parlava al loro
primo video mi capita sai che veramente
giuro che non lo so veramente la ii
ragazzi in un rione dei fan della lava
di federico ma io odio moccia atipica
pacifico poi sembravo lion king non sa è
che quello che adesso stai comprando la
foto che c'è dietro
ma facciamo una nota non appare vedere
una pubblicità
avete mai visto due individui così
rivedere mio ne avete mai visto nei
giorni dall aic sono per quel nome raga
io non so sono sempre contento
orgoglioso di fare video con coloro il
dopo questa hanno mai fatto un video in
cui proseguo della gillette questa
domanda per sapere che ci defiliamo
perché queste cose perché pativano sui
canarini gli altri anche prima recenti
sugli altri canali non si potrà avere un
canale youtube goal abbiamo cercato
degli anni
a partire da quelli giorni quante la
saranno sul canale di colorado voi ve lo
ricordate le alte o certo non
dimenticarlo
anche io so numero fantasia partire
dalle 20 di sera la prima puntata non li
che la guardavo io ero lì davanti
gilardino mette al bando dai a 33 basta
che dite voi suonare ci somigliano san
daniele che accoglie hai ragione
possibile che può non essere una scena
il passato sono eterosessuale abbiamo
anche fidanzato non puoi dire nessuno la
mamma di nella puntata di come sarà il
futuro come si chiamano meno dei
risvolti di natura altro famoso mandrano
dei soldi e figlio di famiglia il figlio
di famiglie ricche di anni l'ultima
domanda ride the last one come si
chiamano i fan della strumento andrea
grigi grazie ragazzi ringrazio pantella
spera vernale ci fanno questo video e io
che sono riuscito a rispondere grecia
mente a tutte le domande che ragazzi
e così è cambiato nomentana e il dopo
spero che video visti a precedere in
caso di panne della star praticato da
questo video tratto di una grande
lezione cosa che al momento lascia che
non c'è una comunità così dice non dice
il vero ragazzi ha mai detto perché lo
dico da pagare prevediamo che il quadro
[Musica]